Je vais bien.
Je suis en état aujourd'hui de reprendre
mes activités.
J'ai été - je le souhaite perçu comme tel
- transparent sur le fait que j'avais un cancer.
Je ne veux pas employer des termes pour dire
'j'ai vaincu'...
Je veux dire merci à tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu.
Aujourd'hui, je suis en état de retravailler
et heureux de le faire.
Donc je vais bien.
- Pourquoi cette volonté de transparence
? C'est plutôt rare ?
Je devais ça en tous les cas à mes élus
et surtout aux habitants de Dijon.
Ils me connaissent.
Ils me voient tout le temps.
J'y habite, c'est ma ville de cœur.
Ça fait presque vingt ans que j'en suis le
maire.
J'ai quitté mes fonctions ministérielles
pour revenir à la mairie.
Donc j'ai senti un formidable besoin de transparence,
qui s'est traduit par un formidable mouvement
de soutien,
qui m'a beaucoup aidé dans la lutte contre
le cancer.
- Comment vous vous projetez à Dijon ?
Je suis le maire.
Je suis président de la métropole.
Il y a du travail.
J'ai une première adjointe qui m'a remplacé
pendant ma lutte contre la maladie.
Elle l'a fait très bien.
Donc je suis content de voir que des gens
sont aptes, le moment venu sûrement, à prendre
la succession.
Le moment n'est pas encore venu, je suis le
maire.
Et je reste le maire.